[Musique]
on va parler maintenant de deux cultures
et des 400 ans de molière ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que molière va
avoir quatre cents c'est pas rien mais
qu'il est toujours d'actualité la
fameuse phrase de guitry quoi de neuf
molière est sur toutes les lèvres et en
titres de tous les artistes alors un
molière 400 ans et toutes ses dents
c'est vraiment ça on va parler avec
christophe mauric et décrivent un kit
homme de théâtre qui est un des grands
spécialistes de mode hier il a écrit
notamment la biographie de mode hier
chez folio et marquise la nouvelle
comédienne de molière c'est ballan
bonjour christophe ses bons jours
patrice bonjour à tous
il ya une chose qui frappe
christophe c'est que ya souvent des
hauts et des bas chez les ch et des
grands auteurs il n'y a pas tellement
une bâche et chez molière et c'est une
star et de succès c'était déjà une star
de son vivant
oui absolument d'abord il faut quand on
voit le le l'inventaire après le décès
de la richesse de molière elle est
considérable il ya à peu près 60 kg
d'argenterie un clavecin il ya des
oeuvres d'art et mon père a toujours été
riche molière a toujours couru après
l'argent et me lire a toujours eu
énormément de succès dès lors qu'il se
mette sous la protection de monsieur le
frère du roi puis du roi à partir de 758
donc oui c'est une star et on vient l'on
vient le boiron vient voir le comédien
parce que il fait rire parce que il fait
des annonces au théâtre en gesticulant
mimant saint jean en imitant et tout le
monde s'y retrouve
alors c'est une star française mais il
est aussi assez vite connu en angleterre
assez vite connu aussi en russie ce qui
devrait pas des retraites non qu'est ce
qui explique selon vous justement cette
universalité du succès de bol hier moi
c'est d'abord l'inventeur vraiment de la
comédie de moeurs certes on avait une
corneille avec
le menteur la suite du menteur et les
autres comédies mais molière va avoir
des personnages des comédies qui sont à
la fois le verre à moitié vide et à
moitié plein c'est à dire que on à
filain et alceste on a eu dans le
misanthrope par exemple et on va avoir
une comédie à l'italienne je pense à ce
cap 1 et au personnage de mascaret qui
reprend harlequins on va voir cette
comédie à l'italienne mais une comédie
qui met très française finalement parce
qu'elle va reprendre les caractères
français
alors on va on va revenir voter sur
l'oeuvre après un peu quelques mots sur
lui souvent on en a fait quelqu'un qui
était comme ça un certain banque était
né dans un milieu pour pas du tout c'est
un milieu bourgeois quoi dans le cabinet
la famille poquelin est riche
elle est très artiste du côté créé c'est
du côté de la mère ou une pratiquement
tous les autres l'étant de son musicien
elle est
le petit pot qu'un va est élevé chez les
jésuites au collège de clermont donc au
milieu des de la crème
social vous voulez et lorsque il quitte
paris en 42
présent d'été c'est le père qui va de la
caution pour le faire sortir de prison
il a été en prison que 24 heures au
châtelet mais mais qui va payer la
caution de dix mille livres ce qui
représente environ 110 mille euros ouais
d'accord donc oui c'est ça c'est plus un
milieu plutôt aisé est plutôt riche
parfois on en a fait c'est ça une sorte
d' enfant de la balle c'est pas tout à
fait ça qu'est ce qui fait qu'à 21 ans
alors qu'il avait fait des études
d'autres groupes de droite notamment
enfin qu'est ce qui fait qu'à 21 ans il
se tourne vers vers le théâtre c'est là
c'est la rencontre avec avec madeleine
béjart
indiscutablement il va il ya
certainement été passionné par le
théâtre depuis tout petit on raconte que
il traduisait les pièces de terence déjà
au collège de clermont enfin ça c'est un
peu de la légende et ensuite il va
tomber amoureux de madeleine béjart
alors les béjart ils sont nombreux
il ya le père et la mère marie hervé ya
geneviève il ya le frère qui est bègue
et ils rêvent les béjart de jouer parce
que madeleine à une très grande ambition
elle veut rentrer à l'hôtel de bourgogne
c'est à dire parmi les comédiens du roi
et par conséquent elle va monter cette
troupe de théâtre l'illustrent théâtre
et on peut se demander si molière enfin
le jeune aucun n'est pas un peu le
pigeon c'est à dire que il a de l'argent
donc on va le faire des décors faire des
costumes et puis de changer à un jeu de
paume en théâtre tout ça coûte
énormément d'argent et c'est un peu pour
qu'un dit pas et derrière donc
madeleine est elle vraiment très
amoureuse de jean baptiste faut savoir
aussi que ll s'est émancipé dès l'âge de
16 ans qu'elle a deux enfants avec le
compte de modène et avec qui elle dit
avec qui elle terminera sa vie
donc la place de pau cas là dedans et
les uns je pense que les belges arlon un
peu prise des prises en otage il y aura
madeleine déjà il y aura aussi armande
c'est la fille de madeleine
on peut dire ça un peu vulgaire mais
comme le dit très justement barbier dans
son joli livre le monde de molière pour
pour molière le sexe et la vie et donc
il va avoir une vie une vie sentimentale
et sexuelle extrêmement fourni alors
vous avez écrit une biographie
d'informer la biographie de molière chez
folio gallimard folio
c'est pas facile d'écrire une biographie
parce qu'au fond à l'époque on a peu de
peu de données peu de documents ils ne
venaient pas de journaux ont raconté pas
tellement la vie des uns et des autres
c'est vrai que c'est alors comment
comment il est et molière ou est-ce
qu'il était plutôt côté il écrit ni
comédie mais ce héros c'est pas rigolo
dans la vie ici
alors non c'est un observateur c'est un
rigolo c'est un grand et très très drôle
quand il est en petit comité et quand il
est sur cet événement mais dans la vie
de tous les jours il est plutôt réservé
moi je le peux je compare un peu à
edouard baer vous voyez un type pas très
grands empires gars qui sourit qui fait
un peu timide comme ça et puis des
comptes relâche alors là il se lâche
adacore way et c'est vrai que il y a un
peu tout ce qu'on a dit mais je crois
que c'est assez vrai il ya un peu tous
ces personnages en lui c'est à dire
qu'il a à la fois le misanthrope tropez
et séducteur il a foi dont jean et
sganarelle 1 il ya peu ça non oui vous
posiez la question des difficultés de
sources lorsqu on décrit une api de
molière en réalité tout est dans son
théâtre parce que son théâtre est très
autobiographique tous les personnages
c'est un peu lui c'est à dire cette
espèce de tyran domestique
ce sont ses travers et lorsqu'il dit que
il écrit des comédies pour corriger les
travers des hommes ce sont ses travers à
lui en premier et lorsqu'il fait sa
grande dépression nerveuse ou son burn
out comme vous voulez en 766 il va se
moquer de lui même il écrit le
misanthrope et il se met dans la place
d'alsace
alors reparler de de madeleine et
d'armes au béjart la mère et la fille
qui ont été cccb trait sans fin et puis
il y en a une autre alors avec elle vous
consacrer un livre marquise la sensuelle
comédienne de molière c'est la marquise
du parc
alors là c'est un personnage
époustouflante dire que c'est une
séductrice total elle a séduit
absolument tout le monde
c'est la star c'est à dire que elle est
très belle et on a une description
précise de son physique dans le mariage
forcé ou il parle d'eux vos petits yeux
éveiller votre petit nez fripons vos
lèvres appétissante vos oreilles
amoureuse votre petit menton joliveau
petit et on rondelet donc comme il
décrit le le le personnage décrit la
femme qui est devant lui on a donc cette
description précise du physique de
marquise du parc marquise du parc
s'appelle marie thérèse gaulle à son
père est italien et elle est à lyon et
elle fait un peu le petit singe à danser
autour
dieu l'âge de la charrette du père qui
vend des ombres d'accord et c'est comme
ça que
les
comédiens de l'illustré théâtre qui sont
en tournée à lyon à ce moment là la
repère et forcément ils sont tous
séduits par cette fille qui intègre la
troupe et qui va poursuivre le chemin
avec le avec l'illustré théâtre alors
comme buzz naturellement tout le monde
la regarde et tout le monde l'a relooké
tout le monde la dezir il va falloir
bien la marier parce que moins ça
évitera de dissocier les couples au sein
de la troupe et on va la mariée
c'est un type merveilleux gentil sympa
est ce que j'écris dans la biographie
romanesque comme vous que vous vous êtes
présenté qui sort cette semaine
elle a en fait deux secrets marquise
le premier secret c'est qu'elle a de
très grandes oreilles elles traitent
très mal les cachent toujours et ça on
le voit dans la promptitude versailles
où vous avez armande naturellement
jalouse qui vient la voir perverse en
remontrer noir vos cheveux et elle fait
ressortir les oreilles et c'est là c'est
pas écrit pour rien cette histoire et
puis la deuxième chose c'est qu'elle ne
sait ni lire ni écrire ça c'est
formidable et ça c'est le secret qui
fait que c'est berthelot qui va lui
apprendre ses rôles alors quels sont les
rôles c'est pas des grands rôles elle va
jouer si dans deux troisièmes rôles oui
dans leur imaginaire elle va jouer la
nuit dans les aventures de diane elle va
jouer elvire dans ton gars yves navarre
une marquise dans la prude versailles
marquise elle même et puis elle va jouer
quand même arsinoé
dans que le misanthrope pourquoi parce
que la plupart des verts d'arsinoé sont
des verts de dont bercy de lavardens
qu'elle n'avait pas besoin de
réapprendre le texte d'accord alors
ensuite elle va trahir molière parce que
tout le monde la veut alors en 758
lorsqu'ils vont à rouen rencontré
corneille pour lui demander
l'autorisation de le jouer ça devait
durer huit jours ça va durer six mois
parce que corneille ne veut pas lâcher
la troupe tant qu'il n'a pas eu les
faveurs de
ses incroyables et va écrire ce fameux
sonné vague que dolan connaît marquises
un visage à quelques traits eux à
quelques traits un peu vieux souvenez
vous qu'à mon âge vous ne voudrez guère
mieux guerrieri et brassens a mis ça en
chansons avec la réponse de marquise g20
en moins chers vont me corneille et je
t'emmerde en attendant alors après je
vais renvoyer à votre biographie parce
que malheureusement là on a on n'a pas
le temps de tout tout d'abord db c'est
formidable parce que c'est alors qu'on
parle de corneille racine aussi enfin
est incroyable et elle va mourir 68 d'un
avortement raté
est tout neuf à croire que ses racines
qui l'a tué or elle il a créé le rôle
d'andromaque andromaque c'est pas le
grand rôle dans la pièce d'entre eux
c'est c'est hermione et là on met
andromaque c'est comme sur bt catherine
deneuve si vous voulez eux et donc est
donc tout le monde y va pour voir marty
dedans alors moi ce qui m'intéressait
dans ce dans ce livre dense heureux dans
cette biographie romanesque de marquise
c'est que on comprend mieux les rapports
avec corneille on comprend mieux les
rapports avec racine corneille qui
arrive en 750
559 qui arrive de rouen qui quittent
rouen définitivement et qui signe un
contrat pour kippour marquise et
berthelot ronronner pour qu'il vienne
dans la troupe du marais donc il fait
encore un coup de à molière et
etc
vient pas là dessus mais c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles vous êtes un de
ceux qui sont persuadés que corneille
n'a jamais écrit qu'on me l'a dit les
pièces de molière mais bon je vous
laisse passer
il a contribué à pacifier ses marques et
oui mais le reste parce qu'après on a
beaucoup dit que molière n'avait rien
écrit que ces corneilles qui avait tout
écrit vous êtes de ceux qui qui ne pense
pas un mot
il ya un acteur très monnier rien qui a
dès hier et crée le dictionnaire
amoureux de de molière qui francis
huster qui demande sa panthéonisation
pour le 400e anniversaire ça sera un bon
signe
écoutez ça serait formidable mais au
panthéon en dehors de voltaire et de
rousseau il n'y a que des gens d'après
la révolution française
commence à ouvrir à l'ancien régime
alors on va mettre jeanne d'arc on va
mettre le sully on va mettre colbert
alors là on va lancer des polémiques à
chaque fois donc le mieux c'est de
garder la règle que le panthéon
au panthéon sont les grands hommes et
les grandes femmes la patrie
reconnaissante la patrie après la
république merci infiniment
christophe borie j'envoie donc avant de
livrer la biographie de molière chez
folio et marquise la sensuelle
comédienne de molière c'est chez balland
et puis il y aura beaucoup beaucoup de
dommages à molières sur ce territoire
notamment à versailles à saint germain
et vous retrouverez tous évidemment sur
le site de tv 78 merci beaucoup
christophe maury merci patrice et bonne
année